you
hi everyone is Jerry let's have a look
at a game that was played at the Vienna
tournament 1908 on the white end Akiba
Rubinstein one of the very best players
if there's talk of greatest chess
players never to become world champion
don't be surprised to hear his name
surface his opponent Aldrich Duras a
leading Czech player at the time and he
was also a chess composer the game we're
about to see has a nice middle game
combination that produces a small
material plus for the first player and
from there we get to see one of the very
best endgame players show his clean
technique so let's see how this one
plays out have a queen on battle black
first to strike at the white center a
simple start with III after Knight f6 we
have a capture on c5 and so it already
becomes important at this early stage
for black you know how exactly to
recapture the poem simplest would be e 6
and blacks prepared to develop and
recapture black has a roundabout way of
recapturing the pawn in this game
however notice if a 6 in the b4 moves we
have the typical undermining maybe even
B 6 is involved depending how determined
white is to try and hang on to the pawn
it cannot be hung on to in this game
what do we have we have Queen to a5 it
seems fine maybe on the surface you just
give a check you pick up the pawn but
this is not a good approach and I know
it's early we're at move 5 here I'm
gonna throw a pop quiz your way how
exactly to block this check what move
would you play in this position I'll
give you five choices c3 Knight c3
Knight d2 Bishop d2 Queen d2 feel free
to pause the video okay in the game the
absolute
best night B - D - why can I speak so
confidently about this aside from
knowing that this is the top
recommendation of the computer what is
it about this position that tells me
Knight B to d2 is best well for starters
I can eliminate choice a and B namely c3
and Knight c3 because that interferes
what white wants to do in this position
y wants to play the move c4 white wants
to challenge the black center this is
let me just clear the board here for a
moment when I see this position one of
the things I think about is play will
ensue on the queenside this structure
for white this structure for black
probably already anticipate there will
be upon on e6
it will go unchanged it remains
symmetrical play will ensue on the Queen
side there will be pawns launched with
c4 maybe a 3 b5 maybe black expands with
a6 b5 this is where the action will be
Queen to a5 is losing some time right
now she's going to take two moves
capturing on c5 at this stage and we're
not done yet
additional Tempe can be gained against
the Queen and we see this with White's
next move starting first with a three
where do you think the bishop wants to
be on the main diagonal which means the
b-pawn needs to move and great the Queen
is now going to get a punch so blacks
gonna have to lose some time know that
there is not a convenient way to stop
the move before either in this position
a5 does not do this because b4 can still
be played if captures this would be
embarrassing for black Queen and rooker
hit game over okay black responds
straightaway anticipating the move be
for Queen c7 notice this isn't the
safest square for the Queen eventually
it'll be a little bit uncomfortable
there because rook c1 will be on board
soon enough this C file you need to
already view it as being opened c4 will
be in and the C file will open right now
c4 on board captured two ways to
recapture we have Knight takes e4 both
are kind of equal ish no you know you
look at the evaluations they kind of say
the same about the moves Knight takes e4
and Bishop takes c4 I kind of liked the
knight c4 move even though it isn't
developing a new piece it's a nice
improvement for the night going from the
second rank to the fourth rank and
should be for be in there and the knight
ever is ever kicked the square a five
might be pretty good as well or even a
five okay I guess you could kind of flip
a coin on that one continuing we have
knight c6 be for Bishop to g4 with a pin
Bishop b2 and now we have b5 so where
exactly does the knight go in this
position move 10 now well move 11 coming
up here what did Rubenstein play next
feel free to pause the video okay well
in the game we have this is the nice
combination I was referring to at the
start of the video we have the move
Knight to e5 and it seems like that this
is a bit of a blunder because there is
this pin and the knight is not reliable
for the defense of the night but let's
see what this idea is exactly Knight
takes Knight well what does white do
actually offers up the Queen
right was this pin well how much of a
pin was at how serious of a pin was it
not so serious Bishop takes Queen does
occur and we don't have the immediate
recapture Bishop takes b5 check and
Knight to d7 follows know one of the
things that drew me into this game was
one of these what-if scenarios in the
game it was Knight to d7 but what if the
King goes here just a quick preview
ninety seven happens in the game we have
a capture and a recapture black is quick
to give the Queen right back and it's
one of the one of the better choices by
black but what if black tries to hang on
to the Queen doesn't play Knight to d7
this is this is a really cool
combination I found one or one of the
best combinations I'd say that I've seen
this is what would happen if the King
tries to run in black tries to hang on
to the Queen capture let's say the King
continues to run watch this you ready
one more pop quiz in this situation what
would white be able to do in this
position feel free to pause the video
okay what am I about to show you the
solution
it's a checkmate in four feel free to
try it again if you didn't come up with
a mate and four white would have this
star move knight c6 you got to take the
knight Bishop e5 check
and if the Queen blocks here made on the
spot and after Queen d6
it's a mountain - from this point we
would have this cool move rook c1 and
there's nothing to do
this main threat on CA there's only one
way to stop a rook c8 mate next and that
would be to play Queen here but in that
case we would take with the Bishop for
me anyhow a pretty cool combination that
could could have come about should black
have bolted with the King and tried to
hang on to the Queen in this position in
this game we have 97 and an immediate
capture on d7 even better is to take on
d1 just piling up on this pin tonight
but okay this is still producing an
advantage capturing on d7 black gives
the Queen right back trying to run over
here that's not going to end well
rook takes Bishop and we have three
minor pieces and a rook attacking the
King there'd be a discovered check in
the air as well as a mate threat to many
threats for black to parry so black
gives the Queen right back
Knight takes Queen the bishop is rescued
and now let's just pause for a moment
things have changed quite a bit
we are certainly approaching an endgame
here and game on board right now white
is up upon because of this middle game
combination how exactly to convert this
in a smooth way you know how to do it
where you're not allowing counter play
by the opponent the
that is up for white is the beep on two
versus one on the queenside at the
moment the night is under fire so first
things first where exactly to put the
night the best square is 'if I've moved
played in the game and why is this best
well one of the things that black has in
his back pocket is the bishop pair
95 is aimed at this positive that's
right here is to hunt down the bishop
with g4 and negate the one advantage or
the one plus that black has in this
position of the bishop pair that's going
to be negated and from there the only
thing seen in the position is a material
plus for white so continuing rook c8 g4
white takes out the bishop one of the
one tiny downside connected with this
exchange is that it brings this rook to
life and h2 is a bit sensitive but we
have we have action towards the Queen
side here a 7 is going to be targeted
right now strong post now for the bishop
on d4 pawn gets out of the way
definitely can not afford to lose that a
pawn you lose the a pawn these two pawns
the a be pawns become connected past
well there are they already are
connected don't want them to be both
passed from here King to d2 not allowing
any activity improving the King no time
to castle here this isn't one of those
well let's just go here we defend and
then get over here now the King needs
play an active role and well it
satisfies a defensive role as well with
D - no rook c2 from here f6 this is a
strong post for the bishop black wants
to challenge it with pawn to e5 if black
is playing B 6 here black is still not
in position notice to deploy the bishop
because of this pressure on g7 so f6
first and then e 5
the bishop along the main diagonal from
here well white is up upon and is
welcome to even exchanges and even
welcome to giving up a little bit of
material in order to hunt down this
prize on a6 so Rick a c11 rook is off
'if I've more exchanges the bishops are
going to be coming off shortly there
goes the H pawn material is bounced now
bishops are gone and f2 is under fire
what is white to first addresses the
threat that black has King to e2 and
let's pause for a moment in this endgame
rook and pawn endgame position where the
weak points for each side for white
I guess g4 a bit vulnerable maybe a
three but once this is in the rook would
be there defending a3 a six is certainly
weak the King won't be there to defend
and maybe g4 is weak and just keep it as
these two as the weak points and both
will fall soon enough in this game first
black plays King pawn to e4 going
straight in to when this pawn could be
met with King to f3 counter attack and
defense of G form so first black cancels
out the King f3 move white goes in
hunting the a6 pawn there's no way to
defend it
rook g2 rook takes a rook takes G with
this exchange with this capture on g4 no
passed pawns are produced for black
whereas with the capture on a2 are
produced for white the last last thing
to really note about this position is
the king the white king is not
necessarily needed
his endgame having two connected passers
with the rook they are assisting is some
many times good enough sometimes it can
come at a snail's pace if the if this
rook was very active and behind the
pawns will soon have that but we're
gonna see how fast these pawns can
really be especially when we have a
white rook that is established on the
seventh rank that's we that's what we
have on this move 28 first white cuts
off the King black gets active with the
rook and white advances that furthest
advanced pawn rook b1a4
fans what is the king to do it's cut off
from here rugby seven
rook a1 and one more last pop quiz in
this game what move did team white play
next feel free to pause the video okay
in the game no need to defend the ape on
this beep on is fast enough b6 rook
takes a follows rook a 7
this rook is there to defend the pawn
once it's on the seventh and because
White has earlier cut off the king with
the rook a seven move the rook will also
be able to support the pawn on the last
rank because rook a eight will hit with
check that's one of the benefits you get
with this rook on the seventh rank in
this particular case cannot afford to
capture the rook white recaptures and
promotes next in the game is rook b4 b7
and there's nothing to do about rook e8
and then promotion King here you could
push with a discovered check so from
here we just have a few more moves g4
rook e8 we get a queen and this is of
course winning just playing it out a
couple more moves and after move 39 King
f1 team black resigns nothing to do from
here just a rook versus two pawns
position if it did carry out a little
bit more what does black have left
you can't even can't even move the Queen
eventually black is forced to move the
King and this pawn will be dropped and
yeah something like this to break up the
pawn structure and simple enough from
here well that's as far as it got in
this one move 39 King to f1 and team
black resigns so a very nice conversion
here nice combination in the middle game
up upon team white and clean conversion
from there anyhow feel free as usual to
leave any feedback to this video in the
comment section below
hope you enjoyed it maybe even took a
thing or two away from it that's all for
now take care bye
you